okay welcome back everyone so in the
last part we looked at a linear system
of equations X dot equals ax okay so
this is a vector state with n components
and is how many things I'm keeping track
of in my system a is a matrix that tells
me how X dot is a function of X and what
we did was we essentially figured out
that if we found the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a that essentially
defines a new coordinate system where
it's easier to represent the dynamics
and solve them so in MATLAB very very
simple to get a matrix of eigenvectors T
and a diagonal matrix D that has only
the eigenvalues this should be lambda
and only the eigenvalues on the diagonal
and zeros everywhere else and then in
terms of this matrix of eigen vectors
and eigen values it's easy to solve the
system X at some later time T in terms
of the initial condition and these
relatively easy to compute matrices T
again matrix of eigenvectors e to the
diagonal b times time which is easier to
compute because it's diagonal and T
inverse okay and so what we're going to
talk about now is essentially stability
okay so we're going to talk about the
stability of the system which basically
means what does the system do as time
goes to infinity does it blow up does
this all go to 0 does something weird
happen okay now there's whole classes on
ordinary differential equations and
linear algebra and dynamical systems
then we'll talk about phase portraits
and saddles and sinks and centers and
you know all kinds of deep and very
interesting stuff but we're just going
to get kind of the bare minimum that you
need to understand stability here okay
and it all has to do with this e to the
diagonal matrix B times time so this is
where things happen as time goes to
infinity or in this term and what's nice
about diagonal matrix of eigenvalues D
and this is just a rehash of last time
is that e to the diagonal T is easy to
write okay
it's just e to the lambda one time e to
the lambda two times dot dot dot e to
the lambda n time on the diagonals and
zero everywhere else okay and so
basically what we're going to find is
that if any of these matrix
Exponential's blow up to infinity then
this whole mixture so I think if these
eigenvectors T and T inverses almost
like taking some mixture of these
different basic frequencies or time
dynamics these each e to the lambda 1
lambda 2 lambda n dynamics and you're
mixing them up to get what the dynamics
are of your original state ax okay and
so if even one of these blows up to
infinity
then essentially if you add that into
the mix then X is also going to more or
less blow up to infinity okay especially
if you take some random initial
condition that has some component in all
of these eigen vector directions the
chances are it'll have some component in
an unstable eigen vector direction and
that will blow up to infinity okay and
so what do I mean when I say blow up to
infinity well each of these eigenvalues
has a real and an imaginary part so
let's say lambda equals a plus IB and
this is just kind of going through
complex analysis so if I take e to the
lambda T then that equals what I'm going
to write down is just Oilers formula so
it's going to equal e to the a T that's
a real valued function of a two real
scalar arguments a and T times cosine of
BT plus I times sine of B T okay now
it's a little weird in a real valued
system so like let's say all of X are
real they're real and all of the
coefficients of a are real then this
should be real forever so why am I
getting an imaginary here that's a
little weird
basically it's because if I ever had an
eigenvalue with an imaginary
a part for a real-valued system it would
always come in a plus or minus pair so
that I would have this plus or minus
lambda T and I will get a plus or minus
I sine BT and basically the physics or
the math of the situation would be so
that the solution when you take that
mixture and add them up the imaginary
parts cancel and you just get real value
outputs again a little deeper but all I
want you to know is that essentially if
I have a complex eigenvalue a plus IB
this is how it breaks up now notice the
coasts plus I sine this never has an
amplitude larger than one it's always
equal to one and so this tells me if my
solution is growing in time or decaying
in time okay and so if if a is greater
than zero then essentially what that
means is that I have this exponentially
growing envelope maybe my system is
oscillating sinusoidal e but it's doing
so in that's exponentially growing
envelope and it will eventually blow up
to infinity and if a is less than zero
then I have an exponentially decaying
envelope and so my system is going to
decay to zero as time goes to infinity
so this is really simple to understand
if all of my eigenvalues D in D if all
of these lambdas in D have negative real
part in all of the real parts the A's of
all of these eigenvalues are negative
the real part is negative then all of my
dynamics are stable all of them are
multiplied by e to the negative number T
which gets closer and closer to zero as
T goes to infinity and so this system is
stable if and only if all of the real
parts of all of these eigenvalues are
purely negative if even one of these
eigenvalues has a real part that's
positive then that component will blow
up to infinity and it will cause my
state X to also blow up as T goes to
okay so it's really simple to say and
it's also pretty simple to write down
and so what I like to do is I think
about these eigenvectors and sorry
eigenvalues as living in the complex
plane and so if I say lambda is in the
complex plane it is stable everywhere
here where the real part is negative
everywhere in the left half plane this
is where a is negative a real part
remember this is real sorry this is
failing this is real and this is
imaginary so anywhere that the real part
of lambda the a part is negative its
stable and anywhere where the real part
is positive its unstable and this is
really simple to remember is that if any
of your eigenvalues have real part
that's positive its unstable if they all
have real part that's negative its
stable and so a big part of what we're
going to do in control systems is we're
going to start with an a matrix where
maybe we actually have some unstable
dynamics maybe we have a couple of
eigenvalues out here that are a little
bit unstable and by adding plus bu we're
going to try to drive the system into
stability we're going to try to force
those eigenvalues to become stable again
okay so this is really cool and this is
a nice picture that allows you to think
about what we want the system of a to
look like so we can characterize what we
want a to look like almost entirely
based on its eigenvalues because we want
to drive them into the stable left half
plane in the complex plane okay okay
make sense so far
we have a dynamical system the solution
depends on the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors but it's dynamics in time
only depends on the eigenvalues in this
diagonal matrix D if those eigenvalues
and they can be complex if they have a
real part that's positive any of them
the system is unstable and it blows up
so the inverted pendulum has an
eigenvalue with a positive real part and
that's why it's unstable and it starts
to blow up okay
so that's pretty intuitive and I think
again most of us have that that
intuition about stability and
eigenvalues and so the next thing I want
to do is get into discrete-time system
so this is a little bit less common to a
lot of you who have an applied math
background or a background in Oh des and
linear algebra but in control theory
this is really bread-and-butter stuff in
physics we write down systems X dot
equals ax or X dot equals f of X in
terms of this continuous v varying
function X of T but in a physical system
if I have an experiment or if I am
recording data from a system I don't
have a continuous measurement X of T
what I do is I measure now and now and
now and now at these fixed delta T
increments okay so what I actually have
in practice generally speaking is a
dynamical system X at time k plus 1
equals some new matrix I'm going to call
it a tilde times X at the previous time
K and let's be super explicit here X of
K equals this continuous X evaluated at
K delta T ok so I take some system it
might have an underlying continuous
dynamics but I'm going to measure it at
these individual delta T instances of
time and there's some discrete update
that tells me if the state was X at time
K here's what the states going to be at
the next Delta T at time k plus 1 ok and
it's also nice just to write down what
this a tilde is in terms of a so this is
also super simple a tilde is just e to
the a delta T ok and we spend a lot of
time just now deriving that that if I
had some dynamics and I wanted to figure
out what it is that the next you know
plus delta T in the future all I have to
do is map it by e to the a delta T ok so
these two matrices are related
intimately by the matrix exponential
okay but we're not going to use that so
much here
what's really interesting is we have a
notion of stability in continuous time
so having to do with the real part of
the eigenvalue in discrete time there's
also a notion of stability but it's a
little bit different and so that's what
I want to walk you through right now
okay and I'm just going to kind of
coordinate off so the notion of
stability that I want us to talk about
now let's say that I have some initial
condition I'm going to say I have X
naught okay given that initial condition
I can compute the whole trajectory or
the whole set of measurements for all
future times just by multiplying by a
tilde okay so X if I have X naught then
X 1 is just a tilde times X naught right
that's exactly what this sets X naught
so if I want X 1 it equals a tilde X
naught if I want X 2 X equal to a tilde
X 1 which is a tilde squared X naught
okay so X 2 equals a tilde squared X now
I'm going to say that one more time X 2
is just a times X 1 or a tilde times X 1
which is a times a times X naught so X 2
is a tilde squared of X naught X 3 is a
tilde cubed of X naught and so on and so
forth so X at any future time n is a
tilde to the nth power times my initial
condition X naught super simple pretty
useful and what's really cool is I can
take this exact same eigen vector and
eigen value relationship and I can say
well a tilde is just I figured if it's T
inverse or T like T inverse be T and a
tilde squared is T inverse B squared T
and a tilde to the N is just T inverse D
to the N T and so the only thing that
really gets multiplied to all of these
powers is this diagonal matrix D again
okay so in the continuous-time case we
saw that the only thing that got
exponentiated was this matrix D if I
write this in eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
only power that increases again is this
B and so if we have some eigen value
let's say lambda well here it's just you
know lambda here it will be lambda
squared lambda cubed lambda to the N so
if I follow what happens to an eigen
value as I map it through the system
squared cubed fourth to the all the way
to the end what we find is that it's
actually the radius of this eigen value
that either grows or decays okay so in
the complex plane what we have I'm just
going to draw a little complex plane
here complex plane remember real and
imaginary any eigenvalue lambda can be
written as a radius and an angle theta
and I really love this representation
this is definitely how I always think
about complex variables almost always
because I can say that lambda equals r e
to the I theta and when I think about
things in terms of are e to the I theta
and you can convince yourself expand
this out and you get Coast's theta plus
I sine theta and that's exactly what you
get the real part is R cos theta the
imaginary part is R I sine theta or I
times R sine theta so this is true but
if I take lambda to the nth power and
you can convince yourself just multiply
this out n times equals R to the N e to
the I and theta so what happens is the
radius either gets bigger or smaller but
the angle just kind of rotates around
and around and around so if this radius
is bigger than 1 this lambda to the N
blows up as n goes to infinity just like
in the continuous-time case if you know
if this lambda has has a real part a
radius is bigger than 1 this will blow
up as n goes to infinity as time goes to
infinity and if the radius is smaller
than 1 then this will decay to 0 as n
goes to infinity ok so now we have kind
of a dual picture here again I'm going
to draw this
in the complex plane where all of my
eigenvalues have to live so so now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to draw
some unit circle where everything inside
has a radius less than one so this is my
unit circle inside everything is stable
in discrete time so if my eigenvalues of
a tilde live inside this unit circle
where radius is less than one this
system is absolutely stable and if my
eigenvalues is even one of my
eigenvalues has a real part that's
bigger than one everything out here is
unstable okay
because and I have even one of those
eigenvalues with a real part bigger than
one then this term blows up to infinity
and this chain will blow up to infinity
okay
and so I'm glossing over an important
step this is if you if you're at home
and you want to verify this and really
kind of get expert at this what you'll
do is you'll take that expression and
I'm just going to derive it because I
can never remember it I have a times P
equals T times B this is what I always
start with so a equals T be T inverse
not sure if I said it right before and
remember this is also true for a tilde a
tilde okay so that's also true for you
know put Tilda's on all these things so
I have some special eigenvectors of a
tilde some special eigenvalues of a
tilde and what I want you to do to
really convince yourself of all of this
is take this expression a tilde equals T
DT inverse and plug it in to all of
these terms and you'll find that the
only thing that could blow up or decay
is this diagonal matrix D to the power N
and then you can convince yourself to
all of the eigenvalues of a tilde have
to be inside the unit circle for the
system to be stable okay now and it's
interesting because if you think of this
matrix exponential that relates a tilde
and a then that's actually a conformal
map between these two complex planes and
this stable unit circle Maps exactly to
this left
playing under that map e to the a delta
t so I think this is really beautiful
kind of complex variable theory here but
the upshot the thing I need you to
understand and remember out of all of
this is that the stability of your
system in continuous-time or
discrete-time completely depends on the
eigenvalues of your matrix in
continuous-time if the eigenvalues of
your matrix have a negative real part
it's always stable if a single one of
these eigenvalues has a positive real
part it's unstable and in discrete-time
the analog is that all of my eigenvalues
of a tilde has to be inside the unit
circle they have to have radius or
magnitude less than one and if a single
one of them is outside that unit circle
the system is unstable okay now why am I
going through all of this discrete time
continuous time math is because a lot of
times a lot of things I want to show you
in control theory are going to be easier
to understand actually thinking about
this discrete time system plus bu and
thinking about this kind of discrete
chain of events that that walk forward
in time so I for example controllability
is going to be easier for me to convince
you of in discrete time than in
continuous time but I just want you to
know that these are kind of you know
given the continuous time system there's
an equivalent discrete time system and I
can look at the stability in either of
these okay so in the next time in the
next part we're going to look at how do
you get linear systems for nonlinear
equations and we're going to start
thinking about what happens when you add
plus bu and see when it's controllable